The 5th century BC represented the pinnacle
of cultural, political, and economical power
for the city-state of Athens.
It was a true golden age that would go on
to have tremendous influence not only on the
Greek world, but on all of Western civilization.
Socrates was laying down the foundations of
Western philosophy, aided by students such
as Plato, as well as other prominent thinkers
of that time such as Anaxagoras, Empedocles,
and Democritus.
In the arts, Athenian theater was the envy
of the Greek world thanks to talented playwrights
such as Euripides, Sophocles, Aristophanes,
and Aeschylus.
A man named Phidias cemented his position
as the best sculptor of his time when he made
the Statue of Zeus at Olympia, ranked among
the Seven Wonders of the Ancient World.
Not to mention the fact that almost all the
structures located on the Acropolis, most
famously the Parthenon, were also built during
this time.
Other Athenians thought that history was important
enough to be recorded for future generations.
Here we meet an old friend of Biographics,
Herodotus, as well as Thucydides and Xenophon.
The architect Hippodamus of Miletus was considered
one of the founders of urban planning while
Hippocrates pioneered western medicine and
gave his name to the Hippocratic Oath.
All of these great people lived and worked
in one place, at one time.
And then, of course, there was Pericles.
Sometimes, this golden age of Athens is also
called the “Age of Pericles” because he
was there to support and oversee it all.
He was the city’s leading statesman, a skilled
general, a patron of the arts, and an orator
without peers.
Under his leadership, Athens flourished almost
unlike any other city in history.
It is no surprise, then, that Pericles became
known as the “First Citizen of Athens.”
Early Years
Pericles was born circa 495 BC, in Athens,
of course.
His father was a wealthy politician named
Xanthippus, while his mother was named Agariste
and came from one of the oldest, most influential
families in the city - the Alcmaeonidae.
According to Plutarch, (who will serve as
one of our primary ancient sources here) a
few days before Pericles was born, his mother
had a dream that she would give birth to a
lion.
Afterwards, the historian goes on to specify
that, even though Pericles’s personal appearance
was “unimpeachable,” the Athenian apparently
had quite a large and elongated head and,
for this, he was often the butt of jokes of
Greek poets.
Plutarch says that Pericles’s head looked
like a squill, also known as a sea onion,
and that he was sometimes called “Schinocephalus”
or squill-head.
Besides the unusual shape of his cranium,
it was also said that Pericles greatly resembled
in appearance a man named Peisistratus, a
former tyrant of Athens who was not remembered
fondly in his time.
Therefore, as a youth, Pericles did not enjoy
speaking in public and, instead, focused on
his military career as he believed that that
would be his biggest calling.
It wasn’t until he got a bit older that
he became more eager to enter the world of
politics.
Given his family’s high status, it comes
as no surprise that young Pericles benefited
from a good education.
Some of his known teachers included Pythocleides
who taught him music, Zeno who educated him
on the natural world, and, his most beloved
tutor, Anaxagoras who told him about philosophy.
Despite his privileged childhood, Pericles
saw firsthand how fleeting power can be.
When he was around ten, his family’s status
was almost wiped out when his father, Xanthippus,
was ostracized.
Back then, ostracism didn’t just mean that
he got left out of Athenian politics, this
was an official procedure that resulted in
a 10-year exile from the city.
However, in this case, it only lasted a few
years, until the Persians invaded Greece again.
As one of Athens’ most capable military
leaders, Xanthippus was recalled in defense
of the city.
He acquitted himself very well when he led
the Athenian navy in the Battle of Mycale
in 479 BC.
It was a decisive victory for the Greek cities
and, together with another triumph at Plataea,
marked the end of the second Persian invasion.
Xanthippus only lived for a few more years
after that, but he died a hero of Athens and
ensured that his son would be welcomed into
the city’s political world with open arms.
Athenian Politics
Before we get into the details of how Pericles
rose to power, we should try to get some background
on the ruling political classes of Athens.
There are basically two groups that we need
to discuss: the archons and the strategoi.
The archons were the chief magistrates of
Athens and other Greek cities and they had
been around for hundreds of years before the
Age of Pericles.
Basically, whenever Athens was not ruled by
a king or a tyrant, it was ruled by these
archons who usually came in three: the eponymous
archon, the polemarch, and the archon basileus.
The length of their office terms varied greatly
depending on the exact time period we’re
talking about.
At first, they ruled for life, then they were
limited to ten years and, finally, were restricted
to a single year.
With the emergence of democracy, the power
and influence of the archons diminished greatly.
In fact, by the time of Pericles, the office
of archon was mainly ceremonial, with just
a few minor civic responsibilities.
The authority was now in the hands of the
strategoi.
Generally speaking, a strategos simply meant
a military leader; the ancient Greek version
of a general.
However, in 5th century Athens, there was
a board always consisting of ten strategoi
who were in charge of all the important duties
of the city.
While other positions like that of archon
were assigned by drawing lots, the strategoi
were elected every year.
All strategoi were technically of equal rank
and made decisions through vote.
However, as you might expect, some were considerably
more influential than the rest and their opinion
carried a lot more weight.
Rise to Power
Back to Pericles, he entered the political
world of Athens when he was in his early 20s.
The earliest recorded act of his is dated
to 472 BC when he sponsored a play by Aeschylus
called The Persians.
In this case, Pericles was a choregos - a
rich citizen of Athens who paid for the production
of a play, whether he wanted to or not.
These roles were usually assigned and, in
fact, represented one of the few duties still
performed by the archons but, in this case,
it is believed Pericles wanted to sponsor
this particular play to send a message.
Like we said, even though all strategoi were
equal in rank, some were “more equal”
than the others.
At this time, the leadership of Athens was
divided between two factions, one led by Themistocles,
the other by Cimon.
The play sponsored by Pericles evoked the
Battle of Salamis where the Greeks led by
Themistocles defeated the Persians.
People regarded this as Pericles officially
siding with him in his power struggle against
Cimon.
Unfortunately for Pericles, he chose poorly.
The list of enemies for Themistocles was growing
larger and larger and it included all of Sparta
who were friendly with Cimon.
Eventually, after multiple accusations, Themistocles
was ostracized and exiled.
That wasn’t enough for Sparta, though, which
accused the former war hero of aiding a Spartan
conspiracy plot and wanted him tried by all
the Greek cities, not just Athens.
Since this likely meant a death sentence,
Themistocles was forced to leave the whole
of Greece and, of all places, he ended up
in Persia which was now led by King Artaxerses
I, the son of the man that Themistocles defeated
in battle.
Fortunately for him, the king was not interested
in revenge.
If anything, he was happy to have one of his
father’s most capable foes in his service.
The exiled Greek relocated to the prosperous
city of Magnesia where he was named governor
and spent the rest of his days.
Back in Athens, Pericles was steadily growing
in power and winning over the people.
However, he still had a major obstacle in
the form of Cimon . Like Pericles, he was
the son of a beloved war hero.
In this case, Miltiades, the man who led Greece
to victory at the Battle of Marathon.
However, Cimon was also himself a distinguished
military veteran, known for his triumph at
the Battle of the Eurymedon.
He was also richer than Pericles, and could
afford to be more generous in his spending
to win the affections of the public.
It seemed like Cimon had the clear advantage,
but fortunes are often fleeting.
All Pericles had to do was wait for the opportune
moment to strike against his opponent and
destroy his public standing.
He first acted on some rumors that Cimon had
taken bribes from Alexander I of Macedon.
No, not the famous one.
Who knows, Pericles may have even started
the rumors himself.
The important thing is that they allowed him
to formally charge his rival with bribery
and, even though Cimon was acquitted, it still
attacked his credibility.
That being said, Cimon’s fall was ultimately
of his own doing.
As we said, he was close to Sparta.
In fact, he acted as their proxenos - sort
of an ambassador - and advocated for a close
relationship between the two powerful Greek
states.
In 462 BC, Sparta experienced a helot rebellion,
the helots being the lower class of Spartan
society, similar to medieval serfs.
Cimon believed that sending soldiers to aid
Sparta would help cement the bond between
them.
Other leaders were not as eager.
With the Persians out of the picture, they
saw Sparta for what it truly was - their main
competitor and biggest threat.
Even so, Cimon convinced everyone and personally
led thousands of troops to Sparta.
When he arrived, though, he received a very
unpleasant surprise - the Spartans did not
want them.
In fact, the last thing they needed was for
the helots to learn about that damn Athenian
democracy.
Cimon was turned back and had to return to
Athens completely humiliated.
Afterwards, Pericles had no difficulty in
getting Cimon ostracized in 461 BC and exiled
for ten years.
With the opposition gone, Pericles’s party
was the most powerful political entity in
Athens, but it was not led by Pericles.
Not yet, anyway.
It was led by its senior member and mentor
of Pericles, a man named Ephialtes.
He began enacting reforms to restrict the
power of Athenian oligarchs and to expand
the democratic privileges of the citizens,
but he didn’t get to see his policies in
action as he was assassinated that same year.
Nobody knew who did the deed so, obviously,
enemies of Pericles accused the Athenian of
killing his mentor to take over his position.
Such accusations were considered baseless.
Plutarch, for example, said that they were
“hurled, as if so much venom, against one…who
had a noble disposition and an ambitious spirit,
wherein no such savage and bestial feelings
can have their abode.”
He also mentions, quoting Aristotle as his
source, that the killer of Ephialtes was a
man named Aristodicus of Tanagra.
Who he was, why he did it, and how Aristotle
came to learn of him, we have no idea.
The point is that, with the leader of the
opposition exiled and the leader of his own
party dead, Pericles was now able to consolidate
power and become the most powerful man in
Athens, a position he would maintain until
his death.
Athens VS Sparta
When Persia first began its invasion of the
Greek cities at the start of the 5th century
BC, Sparta was the unofficial, but uncontested
leader of the Greek forces.
After Sparta came its close allies who were
all part of the Peloponnesian League, a group
of city-states all located in or around the
Peloponnese Peninsula.
These included Corinth, Elis, Pylos, Kythira,
and others.
Finally, there were the rest of the Greek
states that would probably not have been allies
if they were not fighting a common foe, the
Persians.
These last states came to resent Sparta, mainly
due to two factors.
For starters, naval warfare ended up becoming
a very important factor in the wars.
Sparta did not have a strong navy, not as
powerful as Athens, for instance, or Argos,
or Chalcis, or Chios.
Therefore, these naval powers weren’t happy
that their status in the alliance didn’t
quite match up to the contribution they were
bringing to the war.
Even more contentious, though, was the idea
of a Greek counterattack.
After the victories at Mycale and Plataea,
the invasion of mainland Greece was over and,
as far as Sparta was concerned, so was the
war.
The Greeks won, the Persians left, job done.
But other city-states like Athens wanted to
keep the pressure on and go into Asia Minor
and liberate the Ionian Greek states which
were still under Persian control and had been
for almost a hundred years since they were
conquered by Cyrus the Great.
At this point, Sparta and its close allies
withdrew from the war and the leadership of
the remaining Greek states was passed on to
Athens.
In 478 BC, they even formed their own association
called the Delian League.
The name came from the island of Delos which
acted as a neutral meeting point for all the
members, and also served as the league’s
treasury.
Even in ancient times, historians such as
Thucydides regarded the counterattack on the
Persian Empire as just a pretext to form this
league without opposition.
The main goal was to protect its members from
all future enemies and, although never stated,
it was clearly intended to counteract Sparta’s
Peloponnesian League.
From this point on, Athens’ power and influence
in the Greek world steadily grew to the displeasure
of Sparta.
Over the following decades, the relationship
between the two states became tense, even
though it was still outwardly friendly.
One important moment came when Athens rebuilt
its walls in secret under the direction of
Themistocles.
Sparta insisted that no Greek cities should
build walls, under the pretense that they
would provide fortifications for a foreign
invader if they took over the city.
Of course, what others took this to mean was
that Sparta preferred if the rest of the Greek
states stayed reliant on them for protection.
Well, Athens didn’t listen to Sparta, and
not only did they build their walls, they
also declared themselves free of Spartan hegemony,
capable of defending themselves.
Over the years, the Delian League slowly,
but surely turned into an unofficial Athenian
Empire.
Since its inception, each member was expected
to provide an annual tribute in the form of
either money or soldiers and weapons.
With no immediate wars on the horizon, most
members chose to pay, but Athens instead kept
adding soldiers to the forces of the Delian
League.
After a couple of decades, the bulk of the
league’s army consisted almost entirely
of Athenian soldiers so, in reality, the other
members were basically paying Athens to keep
them safe.
This continued under Pericles who was eager
to keep increasing the hegemony of Athens
over the Delian League.
At one point, he refused to accept any more
soldiers or supplies as tribute, instead insisting
that everyone pay money.
The true turning point, however, occurred
in 454 BC, when Pericles moved the treasury
of the Delian League from the island of Delos
to Athens.
He did it under the pretense that the money
was safer in Athens but, in reality, he used
it to fund his own building projects.
This was bad for them, but great for us, and
great for history as a whole because Pericles’s
most ambitious construction plan was to rebuild
the Acropolis of Athens.
Thanks to him, the city got marvelous structures
such as the Propylaea, the Temple of Athena
Nike, and, of course, the Parthenon .
His spending ways were not always well-received
in Athens.
In fact, they often represented the main criticism
of Pericles by his political opponents.
During the 440s, the other political party
started gaining power again, led by a man
named Thucydides, but not to be confused with
the historian.
The statesman wanted to have Pericles ostracized
for playing fast and loose with public funds
and, for a while, got the Athenian people
on his side.
However, in an example of supreme oratorical
skill, Pericles managed to win back the public.
He even said that he would pay for the construction
from his own pocket, as long as the inscriptions
were dedicated to him alone.
The magnanimity of his offer was enough to
sway the Athenians.
Public spending continued as before, Thucydides
was himself ostracized and exiled, and Pericles
stayed in power.
The First Peloponnesian War
Ever since Athens started gaining power and
influence in the Greek world, it was only
a matter of time before it would collide with
Sparta which did not want any other city-state
to rival its strength.
The year 460 BC saw the outbreak of the First
Peloponnesian War between Athens and Sparta,
as well as their allies.
Just for added clarity, though, this is not
the same as the more famous conflict known
simply as the Peloponnesian War, which we
will talk about in a bit.
Technically, that should have been named the
Second Peloponnesian War, but because it was
much grander, lasted longer and had much more
significant historical consequences, it became
known just as the Peloponnesian War.
Ignoring the underlying tensions in the Greek
world, this war ostensibly broke out due to
a border dispute between Megara and Corinth.
In 460 BC, Megara left the Peloponnesian League
and requested to join the Delian League.
This caused conflict between Athens and Corinth
who were the initial belligerents of the First
Peloponnesian War, with Sparta only intervening
on occasion.
Pericles was reluctant to engage in an all-out
battle with the Peloponnese forces because
his army was spread far and wide, still aiding
other nations in Asia Minor and Egypt who
were rebelling against the Persians.
He engaged the Corinthians several times and,
eventually, managed to drive them out of Megara.
Meanwhile, Sparta spent the first few years
of the war avoiding Athens.
Instead, they battled Phocis, an Athenian
ally, who themselves were in conflict with
the neighboring state of Doris.
Their goal appeared to be to conquer or submit
all the city-states in the region of Boeotia
and unify them all under one leadership.
It wasn’t until 457 BC that Sparta and Athens
finally met in battle at Tanagra.
According to Thucydides, the Spartans won,
but “the slaughter was great on both sides”
so they could not press on the attack and
had to retreat.
The Athenians, however, managed to regroup
and, just a few months later, soundly defeated
all the Spartan allies in the area at the
Battle of Oenophyta, putting a stop to Sparta’s
plan of consolidating power in Boeotia.
Pericles had the advantage, but it went away
in 454 BC thanks to the Persians.
Like we previously mentioned, a large part
of the Athenian army was still assisting other
nations trying to escape the subjugation of
the Achaemenid Empire.
The Delian League had sent 200 ships to Egypt
to help a rebel leader called Inarus.
The expedition ended in disaster for Athens
following the Siege of Prosopis, as most of
their fleet was destroyed, while Inarus was
captured and crucified.
This may have forced a peace treaty between
Athens and Persia known as the Peace of Callias.
More or less, it said that Persia would leave
the Greek cities in Asia Minor alone, but
Athens had to stay out of North Africa.
The disaster of the Egyptian campaign had
serious repercussions for Athens as it lost
its naval supremacy.
Not only was it threatened by the Peloponnesian
League, but also by Greek cities from the
Delian League who wanted to rebel.
This culminated in another defeat at the Battle
of Coronea in 447 BC against all the Boeotian
city-states that Athens had previously submitted.
From this point on, Pericles decided mostly
to stay away from mainland Greece affairs
and focus his efforts on the Aegean where
Athens was most dominant.
A surprise appearance here was made by Cimon,
once the main political rival of Pericles.
His exile was up so he returned to Athens
in 451 BC.
Still on good terms with Sparta, he first
negotiated a temporary truce between the two
powers which, eventually, culminated in the
Thirty Years Peace of 446 BC, thus ending
the First Peloponnesian War.
The Age of Pericles Ends
Don’t be fooled by the name of the Thirty
Years’ Peace.
It did not last three decades and nobody was
expecting it to.
Over the next 15 years, Athens and Sparta
continued to act aggressively to one another,
but they did it by proxy by finding cause
to attack each other’s allies.
The most notable example of this was the Samian
War of 440 BC.
Athens intervened in a conflict between Samos
and Miletus.
Even though Samos was a member of the Delian
League, the city reportedly asked Sparta for
help.
The Spartans seriously considered going to
war against Athens again, but backed out when
Corinth would not join them since they needed
the Corinthian fleet as the only naval power
of the Peloponnesian League.
Strangely, the same cities that were involved
in the outbreak of the First Peloponnesian
War again played important roles.
Megara, which was, once more, an ally of Sparta,
had angered Athens by desecrating one of its
holy sites.
In reply, Pericles issued the Megarian Decree,
banning Megarian ships and merchants from
all markets and ports of the Delian League.
It was the ancient Athenian version of a trade
embargo.
Meanwhile, Athens also got involved in a dispute
between Corinth and one of its colonies named
Corcyra, today known as Corfu.
Conversely, Corinth secretly aided a different
colony named Potidaea with soldiers and weapons
in a battle against Athens.
These were all considered to go against the
terms of the Thirty Years’ Peace and, in
431 BC, the Peloponnesian League led by Spartan
King Archidamus II declared war on Athens
once more.
Pericles’s strategy was to play to his strengths
as much as possible.
Athens dominated the waters, Sparta was unmatched
on land.
He knew that the enemy would come to ravage
his territories, but decided to avoid an open
battle.
Instead, he relocated his people to the safety
of Athens itself and, while the Spartan army
was pillaging his farms, he took his navy
and plundered the Peloponnesian coasts.
Unfortunately, we cannot see the Peloponnesian
War to its conclusion because, well, neither
did Pericles.
In 429 BC, just two years after the start
of the war, the mighty statesman and half
his family were killed by a plague that ravaged
the city of Athens.
The Peloponnesian War lasted for another 25
years and resulted in a definitive Spartan
victory, thus bringing an end to the Golden
Age of Athens, the Age
of Pericles.